welcome to another video in my series on
sound changes I'm sharing the ways that
sounds change over time in languages
I've covered sounds becoming more or
less similar and sounds getting added or
deleted this time I'll highlight a few
other sound change types
starting with Lanisha n-- which means
that a sound is weakened it becomes more
voiced or less restricted this weakening
often happens adjacent to other less
restricted sounds like vowels or
fricatives the nisshin is potentially a
multi-step process Alan I did sound
might simply go from voiceless to voiced
or plosive to fricative while a fully
lighted sound disappears altogether the
Spanish stop that is limited to a
fricative the between vowels so this
word is phonological e Davos most
speakers glide past this middle the with
even less restricted airflow Ballas some
speakers take the Lanisha Nass step
further by omitting the entirely Baus
the path of this Lanisha n-- was voiced
stopped two voiced fricative 2 voiced
approximate to nothing there are two
main paths ala knighted sound may go
down if the sound in question goes from
a stop to a fricative to an approximate
like the Spanish one did this process of
relaxing the airflow is called opening
for instance Tuscan Italian speakers
soften cut to a fricative huh
so dos Cano gets pronounced toast ha no
if the sound goes from voiceless to
voiced and then becomes progressively
less restricted it's called son or
zation we can see solarization if we
extend the timeline for the Spanish word
Davos I gave before that word descends
from a Latin word
those you can see a clear example of
solarization in this progression battles
to dados to Davos to Dallas to dowse
when sounds get weaker becoming more
like voiced approximants we call it
Lanisha n-- what about sounds getting
stronger towards voiceless stops that
happens too and it's called for titian
strengthening turns a less restricted
sound like an approximate or a fricative
into a more restricted one like an
affricate or a stop as a simple example
the yeah sound in you is fortified to an
affricate jaw in the colloquial
pronunciation of did you as didja i'm
going to move on to a handful of other
sound change types so start making a
list
don't fear though I'll give simple
explanations and examples of each one
along the way if a consonant is deleted
but the vowel before it is lengthened to
make up for that loss it's called
compensatory lengthening the proto Greek
word boats foot eventually lost its
depth but ancient Greek speakers
lengthened the vowel o to compensate for
that loss so their word for foot was
bullsh not just boast speaking of the
Greeks if two or more sounds swap places
that has a fun greek name metathesis in
the non-standard pronunciation of asked
as ax the two consonants cut and suck
gets switched similarly Sardinian
speakers say brow for bowl instead of
the expected bottle inherited from latin
towel if one or more vowels change to
become like another vowel within the
same word it's pleasantly called vowel
harmony two examples here first the
easier one Turkish builds words by
tacking on endings but the vowels in
those endings harmonize with the last
vowel in the root word that they attach
to
so the Turkish noun F means house and
the plural is Evelyn houses where the
plural ending has the matching vowel a
but the plural of bina building is
bonala with an up second example the
vowel a in the proto-germanic word for
people was raised and fronted to a in
men under the influence of the high
front vowel e in the next syllable this
change towards a high front vowel is
called boom lot in the history of the
germanic languages like english i'll
cover one more change here we looked at
stress and pitch accent in the IPA for
language learning if the way a language
accent syllables changes over time the
name for that is an accent shift early
indo-european languages stress different
syllables in different words which shows
up in the way Sanskrit and Greek accent
the last syllable in the top or bottom
but the first syllable in Matta or myth
in Germanic languages like English have
fixed the stress accent to the first
syllable and this accent shift explains
why the English equivalents of those
words are father and mother both
stressed on the initial syllable
in just a few short videos you've been
able to arm yourself with a range of
sound change types but instead of
long-winded prose can we capture these
sound changes in concise formulas the
next video will tie up this series by
showing you the most common and
traditional way linguists visualize the
sound changes that I've explored in this
series